you've spoken about richard feynman as
someone
you admire i think last time we spoke we
ran out of time
so i wanted to talk to you about him
who is uh richard feynman to you in your
eyes what impact did he have on you
i mean i think a ton of people like
feynman he's probably it's a little bit
cliche to say that you like fineman
right that's
um almost like when you don't know what
to say about sports and you just point
to
the super bowl or something is something
you enjoy watching but i do actually
think there's a layer to feynman that
like sits behind the iconography
one thing that just really struck me was
this letter that he wrote to his wife
two years after she died so during the
manhattan project she had polio
tragically she died they were just young
madly in love
and you know the the icon of
feynman is this almost this like mildly
sexist womanizing
philanderer at least on the personal
side
but you read this letter and i can try
to pull it up for you if i want and it's
just this
absolutely heartfelt letter to his wife
saying how much he loves her
even though she's dead and kind of what
she means to him how no woman can ever
measure up to her and it shows you that
the fineman that we've all seen in like
shirley are joking is different from the
feynman in reality
and i think the same kind of goes in his
science where
you know he kind of sometimes has this
output of being this awesox character
like everyone else is coming in this
with these
fancy falutin formulas but i'm just
gonna try to whittle it down to its
essentials
which is so appealing because we love to
see that kind of thing but when you get
into it
like what he was doing was actually
quite deep
very much mathematical um that should go
without saying but i remember reading a
book about feynman in a cafe once and
this woman looked at me and
was like uh saw that it was about
feynman she was like oh i love him i
read julia you're joking
and she started explaining to me how he
was never really a math person
and uh i don't understand how that can
possibly be a public perception about
any physicist but for whatever reason
that like worked into his or that
he sort of shoot off math in place of
true science
the reality of it is he was deeply in
love with math and was much more going
in that direction and had a clicking
point
into seeing that physics was a way to
realize that and all the creativity that
he could
output in that direction um was instead
poured towards things like fundamental
not even fundamental theories just
emergent phenomena and everything like
that
so to answer your actual question like
what what i like about uh
his way of going at things is this
constant desire to
reinvent it for himself like when he
would consume papers the way he
described it he would start to see what
problem he was trying to solve and then
just try to solve it himself to get a
sense of personal ownership
and then from there see what others had
done is that how you see problems
yourself like
that's actually an interesting point
when you first
are inspired by a certain idea that you
maybe want to teach or
visualize or just explore on your own
i'm sure you're captured by some
possibility and magic of it
do you read the work of others like do
you go through the proof
do you try to rediscover everything
yourself so
um i think the things that i've like
learned best and have the deepest
ownership of are the ones that have some
element of rediscovery
the problem is that really slows you
down and this is for my for my part it's
actually a big fault like this is
part of why i'm i'm not an active
researcher i'm not like
at the depth of the field a lot of other
people are the stuff that i do learn i
try to learn it really well
um but other times you do need to get
through it at a certain pace you do need
to get to a point of a problem you're
trying to solve so obviously you need to
be well equipped to read things
uh without that reinvention component
and see how others have done it
but i think if you choose a few core
building blocks along the way and you
say i'm really going to try to
approach this before i see how this
person went at it i'm really going to
try to approach it for myself
no matter what you gain all sorts of
inarticulatable intuitions about that
topic
which aren't going to be there if you
simply go through the proof
for example you're going to be trying to
come up with counter examples
you're going to try to come up with
intuitive examples
all sorts of things where you're
populating your brain with data and the
ones that you come up with are likely to
be different than the one that the text
comes up with
and that like lends it a different angle
so that
aspect also slowed finemen down in a lot
of respects i think there was a period
when
like the rest of physics was running
away from him um but in so far he's got
it got him to where he was uh i i kind
of resonate with that i just
i would i would be nowhere near it
because i not like him at all but
it's like a state to aspire to
you